hey there fellow Tech Wizards and mobile
maestros welcome back to our Channel
today we are about to embark on a
training Adventure that will transform
the way you look at your Android device
forever get ready to explore the
fascinating universe of turmerics the
pocket-sized PowerHouse that brings the
power of Linux right to your fingertips
whether you are a coding specialist a
cyber security servant or a curious
Explorer yearning for new possibilities
turmox has something incredible in store
for you imagine having a complete Linux
distribution right on your phone a
virtual playground where you can Tinker
with packages experiment with
programming languages and unleash the
full force of a command line interface
all without the need for root access in
this video we will guide you through the
ins and outs of turmers from its
seamless installation process to its
immersive area of packages and tools
whether you are an absolute beginner or
a Season Pro will make sure you are
equipped with the knowledge to make the
most of this powerful app get ready to
land up your Android experience like
never before so buckle up and hit that
like button if you are as excited as we
are and if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe and turn on the
notification Bell so you won't miss any
of our future Explorations into the
realm of tech vendors without further
Ado let's dive head first into the
extraordinary world of Thomas and before
we begin if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional Wireless
sets to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
and driving a short to Simply Run's
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of Engineering the course link
is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete audio of the program being
offered so stay tuned with us until line
of this video and don't forget to
register your opinion in the comment
section below now let's get started and
the first thing we'll see is what is
turmox so termex is a powerful terminal
emulator for Android devices that brings
the full capabilities of a Linux
distribution to your smartphone or
tablet it essentially turns your Android
device into a command line interface
allowing you to execute various Linux
commands and run scripts directly on
your device Terminix is an open source
project and provides a versatile and
accessible environment for developers
hackers and Tech enthusiasts to explore
and experiment with various tools and
utilities turmox is designed to provide
a convenient platform for developers who
prefer working with the command line it
offers a wide range of Linux packages
that can be installed using the APT
package manager enabling access to an
extensive collection of software and
development tools this powerful tool is
not just limited to developers it also
caters to Security Professionals ethical
hackers and anyone who appreciates the
flexibility and potential of the command
line now moving on to termites features
so access to a full Linux environment
termex provides a complete Linux
environment on your Android device
including a shell terminal and a wide
range of utilities it enables users to
perform tasks that are typically
associated with desktop Linux
distributions the next is apt package
manager termux comes with an apt package
manager which allows users to install
and manage thousands of pre-built
software packages making it easy to
expand functionality and access a vast
array of tools and the next is scripting
capabilities termic supports scripting
using popular programming languages like
bash and python this feature empowers
users to automate tasks create custom
tools and develop scripts for various
purposes and the next is customizable
terminal the terminal emulator in term X
can be customized with themes colors and
fonts to create a personalized command
line experience that suits the user's
preferences and the next is external
keyboard support turmox supports
external keyboards making it more
efficient for users who prefer typing on
physical keyboards especially when
performing extensive tasks so these were
the features we we will have a look on
the limitations of domics so moving on
so the first limitation is limited
access to Hardware resources due to the
security model of Android turmox
operates within its sandbox environment
restricting direct access to certain
Hardware resources like the camera
microphone and sensors although the term
X API provides some interaction with
Hardware it may have limitations
compared to Native Android apps and the
next is lack of root access on known
rooted devices thermax cannot access
root privileges or non-rooted Android
devices which means that certain actions
and configurations that require elevated
permissions may not be possible and the
next is limited graphical interface
support termux is primarily a command
line environment so it may not offer the
same level of graphical interface
support as traditional Android apps this
limitation can be a challenge for users
who prefer graphical user interfaces
over the command lines so despite these
limitations turmox remains an incredibly
valuable tool for those who want to
explore the power of the command line on
their Android devices it offers a unique
opportunity to learn experiment and
utilize Linux tools and Utilities in a
portable and convenient manner now
moving on we'll see the termex use cases
so the first is we can run Python
scripts on it second we can run batch
scripts then we can play command line
games then we have access VI editor then
we have make SSH connections and create
python virtual environment we can
develop apps as long as you don't need
GUI access and then we can also install
additional packages with Pip and PM CPN
Gem tlmgr and other such package
managers and with that we'll move to see
how we can install turmerx on Android so
termex can be easily installed on
Android devices from either the Google
Play store or the Appdroid repository so
I will show you the website or the
Android repository and I will also
mention the link of this repository in
the description box from where you can
download the termix APK and install on
your device so you have to follow these
steps so first you have to open Google
Play store or F Droid on your Android
device so now we'll see a demo on how we
can install turmox on Android device so
there are two ways that is from Google
Play Store and I have Droid repository
so you can see on the mobile device that
the first link is afterward repository
so you can download it from here or from
the Google Play Store and there are also
some resources from you where you can
download from up to down and other
devices and other links but here we will
discuss only two types so first we will
go to afterward repository and when we
scroll down we can see the download apic
option that is 97 MIB so you just have
to click on that and it will start the
download for you as I have already
downloaded on my Android device
so we'll just open the tombox
so this is the Thomas how it looks after
installing
and now you'll see some commands what we
can do on turmox
so the first command is to update the
packages list from the repositories we
can run the command apt space update
and when we click on enter you can see
that it is connecting to Thomas Dot
mentality.web and you can see it has
started updating all the packages from
the repositories so it has been done
so this is what I have shown you the
demo so the commands are easy I will
tell you the commands you can see them
and run on your terms if you want to
okay
so now we will come back to commands
so when you have downloaded the app so
when you have downloaded the app the app
will ask you for the storage access
permissions so you can allow the
permissions for it and if it's not
asking so by default turmox operates in
its stand box environment and does not
have direct access to Android devices
storage however you can grant storage
access to terminals allowing it to
interact with files and directories on
your device so I will tell you how you
can enable storage access so you can
open the settings on your mobile device
and you can scroll down and select apps
or apps and notifications then find and
select term Works app from the list of
installed apps now tap on permissions or
app permissions look for storage or read
and write files and toggle it onto
ground storage access to terminals so
this was all and installing and managing
termex packages now we'll move to some
of the commands so Thomas comes with its
package manager called APD Advanced
package tool which allows you to install
update and manage various package Json
software here's how you can use apt to
work with packages so to update the
package list from the repositories we
can run the command APD space update and
to update or upgrade all installed
packages to the latest version we can
run the command apt space upgrade so
installing packages on termos installing
packages on term marks is
straightforward you can use the APT
install command followed by the name of
the package you want to install for
example to install the nanotext editor
you can run the command apt space
installed space Nano and if you want to
uninstall packages on tombox you can use
the APT remove command followed by the
name of the package you want to
uninstall for example to remove the Nano
text editor you can use the command apt
space remove space Nano so these are the
essential steps for installing termworks
enabling storage access and managing
packages on your Android device with
termex you can access a full Linux
environment and enjoy powerful command
line experience right on your smartphone
or tablet so will have some cheat sheet
for other commands I will show you some
so in this section we will provide you
with a comprehensive Thomas commands
cheat sheet to help you get started with
the terminal emulator the cheat sheet
will include essential commands that you
will commonly use in terms for various
tasks so the basic navigation commands
are the first is CD that is used to
change directory the next is LS that is
used to list files and directories in
the current location the next is PWD
print working directory it displays the
path of the current directory the next
is mkdir create a new directory and the
next is touch that is create a new file
then we have some other commands from
file manipulation commands so the first
command is copy files or directories you
can do that by using the command CP then
we have move or rename files or
directories you can do that by using MV
then we have RM that is to remove files
or directories then we have cat to
display the contents of a file then we
have Nano or VI that is text editors to
create a or edit files within termos
then we have package management commands
that is apt commands so you have already
seen that is apt update that is to
update the package repositories to get
the latest package information then we
have apt upgrade to upgrade install
packages to the latest versions then we
have apt installed install a new package
apt remove uninstall a package in apt
search search for a package in the
repositories then we have networking
commands that is pink to test the
connectivity of a server or website then
we have ifconfig or IP that is to
display network interfaces and the
configurations then we have netstat
netstat that is to Show Network
statistics such as open ports and active
connections then we also have some
Process Management command that is PS2
display currently running processes
scale to Terminator running process and
task automation commands bash or sh to
run a batch script python or Python 3 to
execute Python scripts and you can also
enable other repositories on terminals
so by default turmox user its official
repositories to provide a wide range of
packages however you might want to
explore other repositories to access
additional software or packages not
available in official repositories
enabling other repositories require
careful consideration as it may expose
your system to potentially untrusted
sources here you here's how you can do
it that is to edit the source.list file
to enable other repositories you will
need to edit the sources dot list file
in terms be cautious while making
changes to this file as incorrect
modifications may lead to issues and you
can also add third party repositories
and do other tasks
and this was all for this tutorial hope
you guys found it informative and
helpful now let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hi I'm
Philip I'm 61 years old and last year
iopskill with simply learns post program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
on our first and if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign